welcome back to our new and recurring
segment the experts remember those
prophecies of gloom and doom following
president Trump's tweet that his nuclear
button was bigger than rocket man's we
all live in a world that could literally
be ended in terms of a habitable planet
because of the sad man's insecurities
it's like somebody hasn't told him how
this is reading to the rest of the world
his potential mental instability has
actually now intersected with a single
most dangerous potential issue that
faces us all as humans on the planet
this is in 3d chess this is a child
getting angry and knocking the board
over we to retire the 3d chess verbiage
I'm tired of that so maybe those experts
can explain this North Korea suddenly
meeting with South Korea to reduce
military tensions of Foreign Relations
here to react Gordon Chang author of the
2006 book nuclear showdown North Korea
takes on the world and with me in
Washington michael Fuchs who is a senior
fellow at the Center for American
Progress Michael let's go right to you
predictions of doom and gloom it's all
gonna end trump is a disaster on foreign
policy
suddenly a kim jong un's people are
talking to the South Koreans they're
going to go to the Olympics well look I
think this is clearly a good development
here the north and the south are talking
that is good diplomacy is the only way
we're going to solve this threat in
North Korea I think that President
Trump's comments to date have
unfortunately exacerbated the problem
and I think what we're seeing out of Kim
jong-un
reaching out to the South right now is
actually trying to poke and prod for
weakness in the alliance between South
Korea and the United States he sees some
of the errant tweets coming from the
presidents the South because of the
tweets well exactly a good thing right
so then that couldn't be reverse
psychology from Trump well look I'll
take it right now but again I'm more
scared of president Trump's tweets than
I am
[Music]
no no no let's go to Gordon Chang real
quickly Gordon your quick take on this
well I think Kim Jong on understands
that sanctions are hurting his regime
those are UN sanctions that have been
put in place because of the Trump
administration Plus also you know
dural US sanctions and we see this Kim
jong-un and his New Year's address
talked about sanctions being an
existential threat to his government
also there's anecdotal evidence of so
many instances of people not getting
money so this is a real indication that
the underlying Trump policy of cutting
off money to the North Korean regime is
actually starting to work and that's one
of the reasons why Kim jong-un wants to
talk to the South Koreans because he
wants the South Koreans to pay them cash
Michel closing thoughts real quick well
look I think this is a potential
opportunity for the United States the
real question now is what does the Trump
administration do are they able to stay
in lockstep coordination with our ally
in South Korea and try to actually start
u.s. North Korea see very and she's the
only way we're gonna really address all
right gentlemen we'll have you back for
an extended discussion